a psychology research team from Knox
College this true story just published a
study about what qualities people find
most creepy well how do you even define
creepiness
well it's interesting they do yeah they
say the researchers found that the two
things people find most creepy are
inappropriate laughter and excessive lip
licking that's true all right well their
perfect example that is a truly truly
creepy laugh what's so funny Greg I'm
sorry mr. O'Brien but uh I was just
remembering a joke my lover told me
during a delicious lovemaking session
this morning I'm gonna share it all
right you know I don't run our business
to here okay great so I was preparing to
give my lover Electra some oral pleasure
hey that's more information better it
gets better and she said be careful down
there uh slippery when wet god that was
so creepy yeah Gregory come on it's
cupcake time over here
[Music]
inde that is so gross what that sure
reminds me of something
mm-hmm I feel nauseous I need some water
or something
[Applause]
cut the crap guys hey what's the problem
yeah yeah what's your problem what's the
problem
God we came here to have a nice time see
a show not watch a bunch of disgusting
creeps I'm sorry sir yeah I'm sorry too
sir don't apologize to me
apologize to my wife you were right
Darlene we should have gone to the
prices right okay ladies and gentlemen
this sketch on judgement was brought to
you by the Church of latter-day saints
[Applause]
you